Wir sind ja nicht doof.
Ja, jetzt da will ich ein bisschen sammeln.
Timer. Ich meine, meine Kollegen auch eine Timer.
Ah ja, jetzt geht's los. Ja, jetzt geht's los, die Runde.
Ja. Hallo, guten Tag. Ich heiße Aydin. Ich möchte mit Ihnen das an einem Nestgespräch führen.
Zuerst brauche ich Ihre persönliche Datenkarte. Dann kommen wir zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, Hauptsache jemand guckt mal nach mir. Also ich heiße Alfred Hahn.
Alfred?
Hahn.
Könnten Sie Ihre Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich besser?
Ja. Vornamen ist A-L-F-R-E-D. Alfred?
Alfred, okay.
Und Hahn, genau wie der auf dem Misstaub. Guck, Gerecki, der Hahn. H-A-H-N.
H-A, H-N.
Hahn.
Herr Hahn, ja.
Okay. Herr Hahn. Zwei H oder eine H?
Ein langes A.
Ein langes A, deswegen ist ein H dahinter. Man spricht das nicht aus.
Okay. Herr Hahn. Ich spiele richtig aus?
Sehr gut, ja.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 48 Jahre alt und bin geboren am 14.06.78.
16.
Könnten Sie Ihre Datum wiederholen bitte?
Geburtsdatum, 14.06.78.
78. Okay. Wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege 80 Kilo und bin 1,75 groß.
1,75 cm, okay. Was kann ich für Sie tun, Herr Hahn? Wie kann ich Ihnen heute helfen?
Ja, also eigentlich geht es schon ganz lange, dass es mir überhaupt nicht gut geht.
Und ich werde so ganz langsam und kann mich überhaupt nicht gut konzentrieren.
Ich kann mich überhaupt nicht mehr auf irgendwelche körperlichen Aktivitäten einlassen.
Ich bin so richtig faul geworden.
Und das macht mir halt so ein bisschen Angst.
Ich habe immer Angst, dass da vielleicht doch dann irgendeine schwere Krankheit dahinter liegt.
Wissen Sie, ich habe einen Bruder, der hat Darmkrebs und mein Vater,
der hatte eine Erkrankung, eine Nebennieren.
Also es ist immer irgendwie was.
Und jetzt habe ich halt Angst, dass irgendwas dahinter steckt.
Und das würde ich halt gerne abklären lassen.
Und am Anfang habe ich das gar nicht so gemerkt.
Ich habe gesagt, na gut, du bist nicht gut in Form.
Okay, jetzt was haben Sie?
Und jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich einfach total schlapp bin.
Total schlapp bin, okay.
Und dass ich keine Lust habe morgens aufzustehen.
Weil wenn jemand sagt, komm, wir machen irgendwas, ne keine Lust.
Also ich bin einfach schlapp.
Und ja, dazu kommt, dass ich so kalte Hände habe.
Und dass die Haut ganz trocken ist.
Und überhaupt kann ich Kälte gar nicht gut vertragen.
Und mir ist auch aufgefallen, dass ich oft so geschwillene Fußgelenke habe.
Das kenne ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Seit wann haben Sie gesagt, lange seit?
Seit drei Monaten.
Da fing es langsam an.
Ja, langsam aufgetreten.
Sind Ihre Beschwerden immer da oder wiederkehrend?
Ja, und sie sind immer stärker geworden.
Immer stärker.
Haben Sie Muskelschwache oder Gelenkbeschwerden?
Gelenkschmerzen eigentlich nicht.
Aber ich fühle mich gar nicht leistungsfähig.
Und ja, Muskelschwächen würde ich sagen, ja.
Ja, haben Sie eine Schmerzen, Gelenkschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen oder Brustschmerzen?
Nein, eine Wehtupe?
Nichts.
Okay, fühlen Sie sich nur eine Schlafen und Leistungsverminderung?
Ja, und ich bin ständig müde.
Und wenn ich irgendwo einen Moment sitze, schlafe ich sofort ein.
Was weiß ich, wenn ich im Bus sitze und nach Hause fahre oder in der Bahn sitze.
Wenn es anfängt sich zu bewegen, dann schlafe ich sofort ein.
Ich bin also völlig kaputt.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie. Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für Ihre Schmerzen?
Ihre Beschwerden?
Ich kann das gar nicht sagen.
Also das ist ja jeden Tag, wird es irgendwie schlimmer.
Und ich könnte nicht sagen, womit das angefangen hat.
Okay, gibt es etwas, was Ihre Beschwerden verhindert oder versteckt?
Wahrscheinlich hilft es, wenn ich mal 10 Stunden schlafe.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Oder haben Sie Linderdefaktoren?
Ich wüsste nicht, dass es mir besser geht.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie.
Leiden Sie unter Fieber, Schüttelfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Nee, das eigentlich nicht.
Okay, schlafen Sie gut?
Also ja, nicht so gut. Es hängt aber mit dem anderen zusammen.
Ich habe krasse Polypen in der Nase.
Deswegen habe ich eigentlich Probleme, dass ich nachts keine Luft bekomme.
Ich hatte mal zwischendurch auch ein Gerät zur CPAP-Therapie.
Aber das war so unbequem, damit konnte ich überhaupt nicht schlafen.
Deswegen habe ich das dann irgendwann an die Seite gelegt.
Aber tatsächlich schlafe ich nachts nicht gut.
Seit wann benutzen Sie oder verwenden Sie CPAP?
Ich benutze es eben nicht mehr.
Ich habe das mal eine Zeit lang benutzt, als sich das gezeigt hat.
Dann war das aber so unkomfortabel, dass ich es nicht mehr weiter benutzt habe.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Sind Sie ohnmächtig geworden oder ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, ich bin zwar schläfrig, aber ohnmächtig bin ich nicht geworden.
Leiden Sie unter Atemnot oder Husten?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen oder Herzklopfen?
Nein, ich wüsste nicht. Ich glaube nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Der ist eigentlich eher ziemlich gut.
Ich habe in den letzten Monaten auch ordentlich zugenommen.
Ich habe ständig das Gefühl, dass ich essen muss.
Dabei bin ich oft richtig verstopft. Das funktioniert gar nicht gut.
Verstopft? Seit wann haben Sie verstopft?
Geh so weit.
So, so, geh so weit.
Sorry.
Es tut mir leid.
So, jetzt kann ich Sie wieder.
Wenn Sie sich nicht gut fühlen, können wir ...
Nein, das ist ein schneller Fall. Keine große Sache.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Verstopfung. Seit wann haben Sie?
Ja, das ist alles so in den letzten drei Monaten aufgefallen.
In den letzten drei Monaten? Okay.
Haben Sie Beschwerden beim Wasserlassen?
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen die Ausdruckkonzentration, Taubheitgefühl oder Krippel aufgefallen?
Nein, das kann ich nicht sagen.
Okay.
Ja, gute Beschwerung.
Haben Sie Hautveränderung oder Gelenkveränderung?
Rotung oder ähnliches?
Was mir aufgefallen ist, dass meine Fingernegel total brüchig sind.
Da muss ich total aufpassen, dass die nicht sofort abbrechen.
Mir sind die Haare auch extrem ausgefallen.
Extrem Haare ausgefallen.
Gibt es nur in den Fingern eine Stäufigkeit oder andere Beschwerden?
Nein, ich bin nur insgesamt zu Kälte empfindlich.
Ja, dass ich das nicht mache, wenn es kalt ist.
Ja, haben Sie nur Kälte?
Ja.
Haben Sie gesagt, keine Gewichtveränderung richtig?
Doch, ich habe 4 Kilo zugenommen, weil ich nicht mehr essen will.
Okay, verzeihen Sie, ich habe nicht richtig verstanden.
Wie viel Kilo haben Sie?
4 Kilo.
In der Zeit? 3 Monate?
Ja, ungefähr oder vielleicht ein bisschen länger.
Okay, haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden für Haare?
Nein, ich kann mich überhaupt nicht erinnern, dass ich so einen Quatsch habe.
Ich habe alle möglichen Kleinigkeiten, aber dass ich solche Probleme habe, das kenne ich nicht.
Okay, verstanden. Waren Sie wegen dieser Beschwerden beim Hausarzt?
Ja, ganz am Anfang bin ich mal da gewesen, da hat er gesagt, naja, müssen Sie beobachten, aber dann bin ich da auch nicht wieder hingegangen.
Würden Sie dort eine Diagnose festgestellt oder nicht?
Nein, nein, er hat mir gesagt, ja, das kann ja mal sein und gut war es ja.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie. Ist Ihnen eine Heiserkeit aufgefallen?
Nein.
Und letzte Frage für Ihre Beschwerden, haben Sie Halsbeschwerden oder Schluckbeschwerden?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Oder Knoten?
Knoten? Nein, Knoten habe ich auch nicht. Wo soll ich Knoten haben?
Okay. Leiden Sie an einer chronischen Erkrankung außer Schnarchen oder Apnoe?
Ja, ich habe einmal schon seit einigen Jahren so ein Ekzem am Kopf, das immer wieder kommt.
Und da muss ich manchmal so eine Salbe drauf tun und ich wasche mir die Haare mit so einem speziellen Haarschampon, damit das besser wird.
Und dann habe ich also auch eigentlich ziemlich häufig, aber das ist in letzter Zeit nicht mehr so schlimm, hatte ich immer so ein bisschen vom Nacken her so Kopfschmerzen, aber das ist eigentlich in letzter Zeit gar nicht mehr so schlimm.
Seit wann haben Sie eine Attacke?
Ja, ich glaube wahrscheinlich, wenn ich falsch sitze oder wenn ich eine falsche Arbeitshaltung habe oder beim Autofahren, wenn es irgendwo zieht, dann merkt man, dass es im Nacken schlecht ist und dann merkt man, dass der Kopf wehtut.
Okay. Würden Sie eine cervicale Halsvorfall oder eine Diagnose?
Nein, nein, nein, sowas nicht. Nein, nein.
Okay. Leiden Sie an eine andere Erkrankung?
Nein, ich bin eigentlich immer ziemlich gesund gewesen, deswegen finde ich das jetzt auch ziemlich gut.
Ja, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ich hatte vor acht Jahren, da hatte ich irgendwie einen Arbeitsunfall, da hatte ich einen Kahnbeinbruch.
Einen Kahnbeinbruch.
Kahnbeinbruch.
Ja, und das ist halt operiert worden, weil das irgendwie getrummert war.
Okay, Kahnbein, könnten Sie beschreiben welcher Ort? Ich weiß nichts wegen...
Ich meine Kahnbein ist in der Hand.
Okay, in der Hand.
Nein, nicht Herz. Nein, warten Sie. Ich sage es Ihnen gleich.
Unter Handgelenk oder?
Eine Sekunde, eine Sekunde. Ich meine...
Handfurzeln. Knochen, meinen Sie.
Ja, nur Knochenbrechen. Kahnbein, Hand.
Ja, Hand. Handfurzeln.
In der Handfurzeln, genau.
Ich habe es mal gewusst, aber da gibt es ja so eine ganze Galerie von winzigen Knöchelchen, die haben alle so schöne Namen.
Und ich weiß nicht, da gab es so einen Lernspruch für die Mediziner, aber ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Also, jedenfalls, ja, das ist operiert worden, damit ich meine Hand wieder bewegen konnte.
Okay, operiert wurden. War die Operation komplikationlos?
Da gab es keine Komplikation, das war ja eine kleine Sache.
Perfekt. Nehmen Sie so eine Medikament ein.
Also ich habe einmal dieses Haarschampon.
Ja, haben Sie gesagt.
Ich meine, Haarschampon.
Dann habe ich wegen dieser Allergie Laktulose-Syrup und Lavendelöl kapseln.
Laktulose und Lavendelöl kapseln.
Okay.
Und wenn ich richtig tolle Kopfschmerzen habe, nehme ich auch eine große Aspirin, also eine 500er Aspirin.
Okay, 500.
Aber wirklich nur, wenn es nicht anders geht.
Ja, bei Bedarf nehmen Sie.
Genau.
Und ist bei Ihnen eine Allergie und Unfallzirklichkeit außer Milch bekannt?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergie.
Haben Sie Laktulose?
Ach so.
Haben Sie gesagt.
Ja, könnte sein. Aber nein, ich glaube, das ist für die Allergie.
Aber wie auch immer.
Also was ich habe, ich bin allergisch gegen Pferdehaare.
Da kriege ich also, wenn ich im Reitstall bin oder wenn ich mit Pferden arbeite oder wenn da neben mir jemand ein Pferd striegelt, dann kriege ich mit einmal rote Augen und ich muss niesen und das ist alles anstrengend.
Und dann darf ich kein Diclofenac nehmen.
Da habe ich mal ordentlich eine Allergie bekommen.
Also so einen Ausschlag bekommen.
Ja, gegen Exanten.
Okay.
Ich habe richtig verstanden oder Sie haben Allergie gegen Staub.
Nicht gegen jeden Staub, sondern gegen jeden Staub.
Pferde.
Okay.
Ja, ich weiß Pferde.
Ich habe wegen Geräusche nicht richtig gehört.
Okay.
Leiden.
Ihre Vater an neben ihm Erkrankung.
Und auch haben Sie etwas gibt es in Ihrer Familie eine chronische Erkrankung außer Ihrer Vater.
Ja, wie gesagt, mein Bruder hat einen Darmkrebs.
Und meine Mutter ist vor zwei Monaten ist die ganz plötzlich verstorben.
Die hatte ein Herzschluss.
Aber wir wissen nicht was da vorher an der Kranke war.
Okay.
In welcher Alter ist sie gestorben?
Wissen Sie?
Ja, sie war so 65.
65.
Also sehr cool eigentlich.
Rauchen Sie?
Seit neun Jahren rauche ich nicht mehr.
Ich habe das aufgehört, aber davor habe ich 20 Jahre lang wirklich gut so ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Ja, okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also Alkohol.
Ein bis zwei Bier trinke ich so am Abend.
Seit wann?
Seit wann trinken Sie?
Ach schon ewig.
Also was sehe ich 30 Jahre oder so?
30 Jahre, okay.
Seit ich erwachsen bin halt.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Das habe ich mir nie kommen lassen.
Sind Sie schon...
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
So wie ich weiß ja.
Ich weiß nicht was vollständig ist, aber eigentlich habe ich...
Gegen Kindertrink?
Kinderkrankheit oder Covid?
Covid bin ich natürlich auch geimpft.
Perfekt.
Waren Sie im Ausland?
Nein, gar nicht.
Okay.
Würden Sie von einem Insekt gestochen?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe keine Insekten-Saison.
Okay, ja, manchmal.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Hahn?
Nochmal bitte.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ein Kind habe ich.
Leben Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, natürlich.
Wir leben zusammen, ja.
Ist Ihr Kind gesund?
Ihr Kind?
Ja, das ist fit.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Angestellter in der Forstverwaltung.
Forst?
Forstverwaltung.
Wir sorgen dafür, dass in den Wäldern der Holzeinschlag kontrolliert passiert
und dass da die Wege sicher sind und solche Dinge.
Okay.
Vielen Dank, Herr Hahn.
Ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie andere Fragen?
Ich möchte schon gerne wissen, was man dagegen tun kann, dass ich so furchtbar,
lahm, müde und träge bin.
Ich bin in keinem guten Zustand.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie, aber es ist so früh etwas zu sagen.
Wie werden Sie erst körperlich untersuchen, dann Blut abnehmen und dann ein paar Bildgebende
Untersuchungen führen?
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Könnten Sie bitte auf die Liege legen?
Könnten Sie sich ...
Okay.
Gibt es andere Fragen?
Genau, wollte ich auch noch fragen.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen? Wie kommen Sie mit Stress zurecht?
Im Augenblick eigentlich schlecht.
Schlecht?
Früher war das kein Problem, aber jetzt fühle ich mich sofort überfordert,
wenn man so ein bisschen hektisch wird.
Und ich würde gerne wissen, ob Ihre Haut ist fettig oder trocken ist?
Die ist eher trocken.
Trocken, okay.
Danke schön.
Und keine Fragen.
Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie so weit sind, dass Sie Arztgespräche machen können.
Aber lassen Sie sich ruhig Zeit.
Ja, okay, danke.
Sie sind schwul.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Ihre Beine schwul sind?
Ja, die Fußgelenke, da ist mir das aufgefallen, ja.
Keine Frage.
Ja, hallo Frau Oberstin.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Ich möchte Ihnen den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Kürze dafür?
Ja, natürlich.
Vielen Dank.
Der 48-jährige Patient, Herr Alfred Hahn, ist 80 Kilogramm schwer und 1,75 Meter groß.
Der Patient stellte sich heute wegen seit drei Monaten bestehender langsam aufgetretener Konzentrationsstörung und Fatigue bei uns vor.
Der Patient klagt auch über Beinödem, kalte Finger und Allopäsee.
Der Patient klagt auch über Gewicht von vier Kilogramm innerhalb von drei Monaten.
Die Frage nach Hautveränderung, Verletzung oder Schmerzen wurden verneint.
Die Vegetative Anamnese, Obstbation, habe ich vergessen.
Es gibt eine Beschwerde über Verstopfung.
Obstbation, ja.
Ja, Obstbation.
Die Vegetative Anamnese ist bis auf Insomnie unauffällig.
Der Patient leidet an Exanthem, Koppexanthem und eine Schlafapne.
Nicht lange Zeit.
Nicht lange Zeit, verzeihen.
Und auch eine Sefallie.
Jetzt akut oder nicht?
Verzeihen.
Hat er jetzt akut Kopfschmerzen?
Wegen einer Falschdition oder nicht Kopfschmerzen.
Ach so, ja. Also als Vorerkrankung. Aber jetzt hat er das nicht, ne?
Ja, jetzt gibt es keine.
Vor 80 Jahren wurden sie bei dem Patienten wegen einer Kahnbeinbruch.
Oder Operation durchgeführt.
Operation durchgeführt.
Und sie nehmen zurzeit ACC 500 mg bei Bedarf.
Lebernden Öl.
Nicht ACC, ISS.
ISS, ja richtig. Aspirin, ich meine.
ISS, verzeihen.
ISS, 500 mg bei Bedarf.
Und lebernden Öl.
Verzeihen.
Ein.
Er rauche, er sei, er ist nicht Ex-Raucherin seit neun Jahren.
Aber er habe seit 20 Jahren ein Schachtel Zigaretten geraucht, das entspielt 20 Packungen.
Sehen Sie gut.
Ich will jetzt das Mikro weghaben.
Sekunde, ich will das Mikro weghaben.
So, jetzt bin ich wieder da.
Gute Besserung, ich wünsche Ihnen.
Und er trinke ein bis zwei Wein seit 30 Jahren täglich.
Und die Frage nach Drogenkonsum.
Verneint.
Ja, für den verneint.
Er reagiert auf Pferdehaare mit Rotaugen und Exanthem.
Gute Besserung auch.
Exanthem und Rotaugen.
Okay, Rotaugen.
Und der Impfstatus ist vollständig.
Die Frage nach Reiseanamnese wurde verneint.
Der Vater hat leider eine Nebennierenerkrankung.
Wahrscheinlich eine Cortex.
Morbus Edison.
Ja, Morbus Edison.
Der Bruder hat leider ein Darmkulankarsenom.
Und die Mutter ist vor drei Jahren plötzlich im Alter von 65 Jahren gestorben.
Er sei verratet, habe ein Kind, lebe mit ihrer Familie.
Mit seiner Familie?
Seiner, ja richtig.
Nicht ihrer, verzeihen Sie.
Sie sei als Forstverwaltung.
Okay, okay.
Der Mann ist Angestellter in der Forstverwaltung.
Okay.
Der Forst ist ein Wald.
Vielleicht kennen Sie den Beruf des Försters.
Das ist der, der nicht mit der Knall rumgeht und die Tiere abschießt.
Sondern der, der nach den Bäumen guckt.
Ich habe Forst gedacht, eine Versicherung.
Nein, nein, nein.
Es geht um die Wald.
Okay, Wald. Meinen Sie Wald.
Okay, und er sei Angestellter in der Forstverwaltung tätig.
Die Anämnistischen Angaben deuten am besten auf Hypothreose hin.
Als Differentialdiagnose Anämie und Persnicious Anämie.
Und was kommen noch in Frage?
Und Depression.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ich habe nicht alle Depressionfragen gestellt, aber Depression und es gibt keine.
Was machen Sie denn als Diagnostik mit dem Patienten?
Ja, okay.
Wir werden so weiter abklären.
Wir werden zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Dann.
Wo achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich achte auf Allgemeinszustand, Ernährungszustand.
Normalerweise so als Vitalparameter.
Aber es gibt keine Vitalprobleme.
Ich habe gedacht.
Und achte auf Hautveränderung, Halspalpation, Bauchpalpation, Herz, Oskultation und Lungenoskultation.
Und auch Knoten in der Hals.
Lumpknoten oder auch Schwellung in der Beine.
In den Beinen.
In den Beinen. Wo in den Beinen?
Ja, plural in den Beinen.
Und ich glaube.
Ja, was machen Sie noch?
Ja, in Labor sind großes Blutspiel, Ernstungparameter, Schilddrußeparameter, TSH, Fri T4 und Fri T3.
Und Nierenparameter.
Und Bezwölf anehmend.
In der großen Blutpilkein.
Und auch Elektrolyden.
Und machen Sie auch eine apparative Untersuchung?
Ja, wir brauchen zuerst eine Halsteroidsonographie.
Dann gegebenenfalls eine EKG.
Aber wir haben normalerweise keine anderen Probleme.
Und bei Schmerzen gegebenenfalls eine MRT oder für Servikal eine Tomographie.
Ja, was würde man denn, wenn die Schilddrüsen Sonographie irgendwie Auffälligkeit bietet, was würde man als nächstes machen?
Ja, normalerweise brauchen wir eine Nabelentnahme.
Eine Feinnabelponktion.
Und auch wenn es auffällig gibt, können wir eine Synthographie oder erste Tomographie dann...
Die Synthographie ist eigentlich schon bei der Schilddrüse ziemlich ausnahmvoll.
Ja, mit uns.
Ja, dann halten Sie mich auf Ihre Laufe.
So was wäre denn die Therapie, wenn er tatsächlich eine Hypothorinose hat?
Ja, wenn es eine Hypothorinose gibt, können wir zuerst mit Älteremtoxin denken.
Und auch wenn es Strom gibt, können wir auch mit J-Therapie machen.
Und Chirurgie, normalerweise nicht in Hypothorinose brauchen wir.
Aber gegebenenfalls mit Strom.
So, jetzt eben erstmal Älterexponion.
Und was meinen Sie, wird es den Patienten dann schnell besser gehen?
Nach der Älterexponion ja.
So schnell, aber manchmal brauchen wir auch Vitamin unterstützen.
Anämie, auch Bezöl.
Das sehen wir dann ja, wenn die Blutwerte da sind.
Ja, ok, gut.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Ja, was mir aufgefallen ist, dass Sie ziemlich oft E-Machen.
Wie wir alle gerne, ich auch.
Aber Sie machen das schon auch sehr häufig.
Und was mir aufgefallen ist, Sie haben nicht die Diclofenac-Allergie erwähnt.
Sie haben nur die Pferdehaare erwähnt.
Nicht die Allergie auf Diclofenac.
Ja, ich habe geschrieben, ich habe nichts alle.
Ja, richtig.
Und die Mutter ist nicht vor drei Jahren, sondern vor zwei Monaten verstorben.
Das ist ein deutlicher Unterschied.
Ja, richtig.
Nach drei Jahren würde ich jetzt niemanden mehr kondolieren.
Aber nach zwei oder drei Monaten würde ich sagen, das tut mir leid.
Gut, dann was habe ich hier noch?
Im Alter von 65 Jahren.
Das stimmt ja.
Ich habe vor zwei nicht richtig geschrieben.
Dann, ja, diese Schlafapne kommt ja nicht von ungefähr.
Sondern da gibt es eine Ursache, weil er Polyp in einer Nase hat.
Und er hatte eine abgebrochene C-Pap-Therapie.
Das denke ich mal, wäre schon ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Weil es vielleicht auch darauf hinweist, wie die Compliance eines Patienten ist.
Wenn der sagt, ist mir zu lästig, mache ich nicht.
Sie haben die Diagnose prima gestellt.
Sie haben auch ganz klar festgelegt, welche Laborwerte wir bestimmen müssen.
Und natürlich auch diese Dinge, die er beschrieben hat.
Einige Kollegen haben da ja auch nachgefragt.
Mir gehen die Haare aus, meine Fingernägel sind rüchig, die Haut ist trocken.
Der klagt ja nicht über so ein buntes Bild.
Und alles nicht wirklich tragisch.
Aber jedes einzelne Ding nicht so wild.
Aber insgesamt macht es halt irgendwie, dass er sich nicht gut fühlt.
Die Diagnose war natürlich richtig.
Das ist eine Hypotheriose.
Und natürlich geht es dem besser an dem Augenblick, wo er seinen Lgbox bekommt.
Dann ist die Welt wieder in Ordnung.
Und Zyldrisen-Sono, Synthographie und gegebenenfalls ein Feinland-Biopsie.
Ist auch alles gekommen.
Ja, also ich habe sie nicht immer so perfekt verstanden.
Aber überwiegend waren wir uns eigentlich ziemlich einig.
Und ich glaube, ganz grobe Sprachfehler habe ich jetzt nicht gehört.
Ich würde sagen, das ist in Ordnung.
Da können Sie getrost in Ihre Trüffung gehen.
Wir halten die Daumen.
Ja, gut.
Meine Lieben, ich werde am Donnerstag nochmal versuchen.
Ich denke mal, es müsste klappen.
Es könnte eigentlich nur noch jeden Tag besser werden.
Das ist bisher jeden Tag schlechter geworden.
Aber irgendwann muss es jetzt mal besser werden.
Gesundheit und bitte kontrollieren Sie sich manchmal wegen Gärts, Gastrosevergärerreflü.
Manchmal haben Sie.
Könnten Sie auch Vorsicht für.
Ja, ich muss vorsichtig.
Das weiß ich schon.
Aber wenn man weiß, dass man viel zu tun hat,
dann legt man ja dazu, immer ein bisschen zu hektisch zu sein.
Könnten Sie in der Nacht zwei Kissen benutzen und auch Früssigkeit in der Nacht?
Ja, wenn man neben dem Bett was stehen hat.
Ja, manchmal nicht Gärts, aber wahrscheinlich.
Ich weiß nicht.
Alles Gute.
Vielen Dank für die Tipps.